hey guys welcome back to the evan and
katelyn podcast the podcast where oh
what's that what's that oh we have a
smashing special breaking news
announcement
evan and caitlin have outgrown their
home and they're looking
to move and they're they're house
hunting right now
wow that's really exciting okay back to
you evan and caitlin
i'm so impressed by you look at that
custom
banner wow ah
oh i don't have words that was so good
should we also do the regular intro no
that was it okay perfect
i'm so excited i have so much fun making
these like little obs
little shenanigans that's great that was
great i can't wait to use that
while we're streaming and stuff oh my
god great for anyone who's only
listening there's like an overlay
in the background a newsy background so
so fancy
like like look do you like the the this
is news
this is news live this is news special
report
that's so great i love it i've just been
over here like
secretly giggling caitlyn's like i hear
you over there what are you doing
yeah i heard you well
really exciting news guys we are
searching for
a new home we have severely outgrown
this
it's something that we've we've
i i realize we've kind of been like
ignoring it
suppressing these feelings for a long
time as one does
and and uh i think it's it's you know we
knew that we needed to kind of like make
some changes in our life
so we intentionally reduced
how many videos we had committed to and
then we just wanted to see what
would be filled with that time because
you know we've just been
going and and so we reduced our video
output to two videos per month
and then as soon as that happened like
the first
month we're like we need more space
okay yeah i mean to me it it kind of
went down differently
slightly to me because like we've toyed
with doing
um we've had a few months in the past
where we
only did two videos a month um it's just
the beginning of 2021 was where we very
intentionally were like
setting the schedule from the beginning
of 2021 forward
we are not going to accept more than two
sponsorships
per month meaning we're only doing two
videos per month because we normally
make our videos based on like
whatever we've committed to sponsors
because we don't want to like break any
agreements or anything like that and i
i think we knew before that
that we were that we needed another
house yeah i think it was just like
a little surprising that literally as
soon as we had the time
that became like initial number one
priority but
i think we've known i feel like i've
known for like two years at least
well to give you some context caitlyn
likes to be a very neat person
she likes everything to have a place and
for everything to be in that place
and you know when when she was
living alone in her own apartment before
we started moving in together and
everything
her apartment was tied immaculate
great and when we moved into this house
this house had more than enough space
for the two of us we had a whole room
just devoted to a guest room
yeah we had a whole guest room and then
this room was like a spare room
we just like put stuff this was kind of
our junk room we used it for like
wedding planning we we used it for like
wedding planning when
we were diying all of our wedding
projects and then when you started
crafting and stuff
when you started um uh like working from
home
we set up like you a little office in
here yeah the place where our treadmills
are that's where i set up like a little
computer for doing like some freelance
graphic design on the side
so cute and organized our entire house
was like
tidy there wasn't just like there
weren't just piles of stuff
no piles everywhere and as we have
used this location not only to live in
but also to run a full business from
that's that's just been a lot because
most businesses have like
a shipping and receiving department and
offices and
a filming set and like we're you know if
this if we were running this as a
business
in a businessy area we would have rooms
for that
and all of those functions have just
been overlaid over
our home and we we do like that i mean i
like that our commute is a walk
i like that everything is right here and
we can mix the two so
so well like we can go to a resin port
then go cook dinner and then
you know like we prefer these
these great ways but we didn't buy this
house
with the intention of also running a
full business from it
and yeah and it's just overflown
to a large degree yeah it also uh you
know
it doesn't help that our a big part of
our business
is making things
and sometimes those things are small but
sometimes those things are like a full
piece of furniture like what do you do
with a cat wheel
it's so big you got to find a place to
put that thing you know yeah and we just
keep on making more things and it just
keeps on filling up and
you know there's there's a lot of areas
that you guys might expect are getting
pretty full like our garage
as we get more equipment the garage has
gotten more full
you know like sometimes we'll be doing
like kind of
planning for two projects at once so
we'll have the main
set set up and we'll have tables just
laying around everywhere else
so we can barely walk through the garage
i mean i think that you guys might have
guessed that the garage was
was very full but the place where we're
at right now
this is our streaming desk and right
there i mean
if i reached out a little i mean i'm
exaggerating just a tiny bit but i could
probably touch
our main desk from behind here
yeah this desk rolls forwards and
backwards
so we have enough space in our office
um to do two desks but this is a like
what a 12 by 12 room
yeah yeah the room that we work out of
is 12 by 12
we have two giant two-person desks
and not just desks also like filming and
lighting and recording equipment
yeah and like you know we have a green
screen behind us you're supposed to be
far away
like farther away from your green screen
no
this is it i'm touching it it's like a
it's like a foot and a half behind my
head yeah
um and so like this this room where we
spend
so much of our time we spend more time
in here than in the garage
workshop it is one of the rooms that has
like gotten
worse and it's also like it's just so
full of stuff it's such a pain
to like you know roll the whole desk
back and forth and scooch our chairs
around and like
if evan is at the streaming desk
prepping a stream and i'm in my spot
like i can't back my chair away because
he's had to roll the desk forward
to get behind this one like it's it's
just like a whole thing and those are
those are the two main
business sides of things you know that's
where we do our work
and and it impedes us there is makes us
less efficient there is one more like
room that's been taken over by the bus
by the business and that's the guest
room
because that is also the 3d printer room
the camera equipment storage room
and just like the stuff we haven't been
able like technology and crafting
supplies overflow room
yeah and then some of that is some
personal stuff that we've kind of
stashed in personal
you know it's also where like when we uh
do like a big art piece but we don't
have room for it on the wall
yet it goes in there you know well i
mean like i think that we are the type
of people who like
everything to have a place and
everything to be in the place but like
when you don't have enough places
yeah you when we don't have we don't
have enough closets um
and and the storage areas yeah it's hard
for us to like really
organize that stuff because we know
that the best we can do is tidally stack
it yeah and then we're gonna have to
unstack it again soon
yeah because there's our closet space we
have used it
absolutely as efficiently as possible um
and all of our closets are full and we
live in an
older house where the closets are very
small
you know like i think y'all have seen
one of our closets
in one of our videos the the closet in
this room that's the biggest closet
we've got
the biggest one it's bigger than my
closet or katelyn's closet yeah
it's it's literally the biggest we've
got the biggest closet and um
so there's just not enough closets in
this house like for all of our
our various stuff and the business
requires a lot of stuff so there's
there's just so many ways that we've
outgrown
the space yeah and we could be more
efficient with our filming we could be
like we could enjoy our office more like
right now we keep the windows closed and
everything in here because we want to be
able to stream
and if we have this window that's right
over here um
open then it'll it'll
vary the the lighting of our streaming
so we can't have the window open
so we just like are in this artificially
lit room
majority of our life and um
there's just so many things where we can
just really really improve things
if we like move to the the next house
and plus like
they're just like things that just
affect like i i think caitlyn's
sanity a little bit more than mine like
our kitchen counter
you know the place where we put the
rainbow bench and the workout area
that area is just constantly full of
like stuff that we've ordered and like
mail and processing stuff and like
just it's just so full of stuff
we honestly all the time we need an area
i don't know if it would be
like if we had a bigger laundry room mud
room or if we need like
a small bedroom for this with just like
giant tables but we need like a
processing area
because we're we have to order so many
supplies
for projects and we're
we're just like constantly receiving
yeah well sometimes sometimes like well
like we'll have we'll order all these
supplies that might take a long time or
maybe they're limited or what have you
so we probably have supplies for like
five projects right now if we like
thought about it and counted things out
i'm not sure when we're gonna do them
honestly because we kind of like
like whenever it's like time we kind of
like shuffle things around all the time
but
yeah we have a whole bunch of supplies
from multiple projects often at the same
time
and yeah we need like staging shipping
and receiving we never really ship
anything out but we need a receiving
area
yeah because like we're a business i
don't think it's unreasonable
it seems so strange to think right now
we need a shipping receiving area in our
home
office area but i think because of the
the type of videos we make we kind of do
you know
i mean and and honestly i think that
like
you know maybe in that same room that's
where we'll keep all of our
like cardboard boxes and stuff for like
we don't have when our recycling bin is
too full of
boxes yeah yeah because like right now
like there's
the entryway this is full of cardboard
boxes i mean
it's just the whole house is overflowing
um
but but uh that those are some of the
driving factors
um for like
why i feel i feel like when we started
thinking about this it was a lot more
urgent
than than i kind of realized yeah
yeah because we we let ourselves
we've we finally let ourselves like
fully acknowledge the problem
yeah yeah but actually we've been doing
this process we've been searching for
homes actively
for probably two months now yeah we
started at the beginning
of 2021 sometime in january we started
actively hunting online we are
um yeah we've done two trips
already uh like actually looking at
houses
um and we like pack those full like when
we say a trip it's not like we go see
two we see like eight to ten
yeah in one weekend yeah um so we've
done a lot of online hunting
a few you know a couple trips out but
honestly like it started with like a lot
of research of like
you know the areas and like
brainstorming with me and katelyn like
how many rooms do we need and like you
know what what do we need for this
next house so like we've put
days and days and days and days and days
into the whole
house journey yeah and it's
it's been really good i mean it's
interesting it's like you know when we
look at
like you know houses we kind of have to
look at our our lives and
think of our lives now and how we want
them to be moving forward and
it's it's been really interesting that
like
you know in our search for our next
house we have found
ourselves
i mean that that's a little bit you know
overly uh stating it
but but i i do think that it's been
interesting that like you know
like that that was a big part of it you
know
yeah um
should we i don't think we've mentioned
where we're looking
yeah yeah so we're kind of looking in a
big
area i think that we love houston
we we we really have enjoyed our time
here but
it seems like most of our family groups
are going to be
more in the san antonio austin hill
country
like swath somewhere you know in there
we already have people throughout we
already have some family there
and we have a lot of family members who
are either in the process of moving
there or are moving there in the near
future
and so it just made sense if we were
going to move
to move towards that area plus we like
like hill country austin san antonio
like we've spent a lot of time there in
the past like
um it's not as humid it's not hurricanes
like um i mean you know it has its own
like other
you know any place has like stuff you
got to deal with pluses and minuses plus
sides but
i think that the interesting thing is
like houston is just kind of like a
little bit off to the side
if we live anywhere between austin and
san antonio in the hill country
we can we can get to any of the other
places a lot faster than from houston
yeah it's so much closer like houston to
san antonio or
austin is like three and a half three
and a half hours from san antonio to
austin it's sometimes just like an
hour depending on where you're going
yeah exactly so it's everything is so
much closer over there
you have access to two cities instead of
one city and like all the small towns in
between
um and honestly like the main reason why
we're moving out there is because that's
where our family is gonna be in the
family is important we love our families
yeah so um uh it's it's great and uh
you know we we we haven't fully settled
in on a on a place but i guess we can
kind of say what we're looking for a
little bit yeah well and i think one
interesting thing
in regards to like what we're looking
for and location is
you know we're in a very lucky position
where we're
we're not moving because like we had a
job relocation
or something like that where there's
like a set
new location and you want to be within a
certain you know
time commute time to that spot and you
have to do it on a certain timeline
you know we both moved a lot growing up
and it was because of our parents job
relocations and so it's always like you
got to be there by a certain
day and you got to be in a certain area
and you know we have all this
flexibility
um which is great but
uh it also means that we've had to spend
a lot more time like researching and
really thinking about
what what do we want do we want to be in
the city do we want to be in the country
do we want you know like all these
various things um
yeah in terms of the in terms of what
we're looking for
i think one of the more surprising
things is when we started like
weighing out our priorities one of the
the surprisingly highly weighted things
was like
proximity to like a ton of tasty food
yes we yeah that was one of the things
that we we were evaluating and we were
like we need
both of our families were like really
surprised they're like man you really
value
like food i'm like yes we want to be
like like close enough to a variety
of restaurants and like um yeah
all sorts of different genres of
restaurants too like
like all sorts of different varieties so
like that's like
oddly high up there we want of course
like the practical goals
of like we need more space in our house
and we need more space in our workshop
we would like to have a bigger yard
because we do
you know filming in our backyard and you
know a bonus would be if it's like a
little bit more private because
sometimes we do things that like
maybe neighbors would question if they
just overheard it
it's on fire it's on fire yeah shoot it
shoot it shoot it
yeah we don't want to worry
and so you know that would be like a
nice thing
um you know i think there's kind of like
those are some of our like kind of
practical goals we also have like
some more aspirational things that would
be great bonuses of things that like
you know we would just like to
experience like we've never had a pool
it'd be super cool to have a pool we
don't have to have yeah i wanted to
cooperate
our hot tub yeah yeah but like you know
things like that that would be
like super cool it's not a requirement
but it you know we're kind of like
oh what things do we want to try out or
like
you know having like uh
enough space in our house to like have
uh
you know a little bit more of a home gym
because right now our treadmills
are in the breakfast nook of our house
maybe not ideal it's literally like well
but also
we have our treadmills in the breakfast
nook then we do
like you know weights and you know stuff
like that
in the living room and we just move the
coffee table out of the way but
we bring the like workout mats out and
we put them back
up every time and stuff it's just
reducing all those barriers
to the things that we we want to do
because like we want to work out more
or even like you know it'd be nice to
live on like a little bit more land
for just like scenery or something yeah
like maybe we wanted like
some acreage or something maybe i just
want to like go out on our back porch
and like
sip coffee go on a walk like
around our yard and have a yard big
enough to like go on a walk around it
i don't know like a lot of these things
are in conflict with each other too is
what we've realized so it's like
the more land you want the farther away
from the city you are
the farther away from all the tasty
restaurants
so i mean like we've looked at places
out in the middle of nowhere and we've
looked at places right in the middle of
cities
and like i don't know which one i'm
leaning towards
i don't know and like you can't it's
really hard to get all those things
because
that is super expensive if you want like
a ton of land
downtown you know like i mean i don't
even know if you can
i don't even know if you can i mean i'll
show them in our searches
yeah well we have this are just limited
to a max cost so maybe if we lifted that
they exist
maybe maybe they're just for other types
of people so that is something
that like you know we we know we're
gonna have to make some sacrifices and
we don't really know like
which end of things we're gonna have to
sacrifice on like
do we sacrifice on having a little bit
more space do we sacrifice on
being as close to the city as we're used
to um
so you know and like one thing that we
we thought about and some of you guys
um saw our our dream house streams where
we like designed our dream house
one thing we considered was do we
build new or do we buy something
existing and i think
you know back before this started
becoming more of a reality we
thought like to get what we really want
we'll probably need to
build it you know if we really want
something that like works for our life
and business because
you know not everyone like needs a
workshop like we do that's like a
filming set not everyone needs like a
streaming room that's perfectly suited
for streaming
and so we thought like maybe we'll build
that's what we were thinking of but like
i'm so glad
that we're not doing that because we're
leaning towards buying a house that
exists right now
yeah one thing that we realized when we
started looking at houses
is we'll we'll probably want to be able
to sell the house that we build
afterwards just in case you know we need
to just in case it's not our final home
just in case that's not our final home
and we don't want to build such specific
things into it that we can't sell it but
there's so many things that we can do
to make the house that we build much
more sellable to other people like
you know we want a big huge office with
lights maybe a wet bar or something like
that but we'll just like
market that and build it as a game room
the reason for a wet bar is to have like
coffee and tea yeah
we're not going to be like drunk editing
no no no yeah
you know but also a lot of like game
rooms might have a wet bar
or something and the reason that evan is
bringing that up is because we had just
assumed our office would be in a spare
bedroom
because that's you know what it is now
but then as we started looking at houses
sometimes houses some of the houses we
saw had like a game room
type room that was bigger than a bedroom
and had a little wet bar and we started
thinking like
how nice would that be to be in a
slightly bigger room and have like our
coffee
in the same room no she's like so cool
we spend
the majority of our lives in here or in
the workshop
yeah so we really want to prioritize
those spaces
i want i want like plants i want like
fake plants
fake plants and and like brightness
and like natural lighting natural light
and everything i think that'll really
like
help us it'll be good for us um
or or things like you know when i
initially sketched up the workshop
it was just this like massive warehouse
but like one thing that we can do
we can build it as like a like six
six-car garage
or something like that and then that way
it's understandable to other people
like like oh i can use more garage space
everyone can use more garage space
so like you know there's all of these
things that we
realized we could like you know when we
eventually do
build our house um that we need to do it
this way instead of the way we are
originally thinking and then that made
us realize
we aren't ready to build like our own
house we don't know what we need
we don't really know how much we need to
expand everything
because we're so cramped right now if we
try to like build a house
i think we're just gonna potentially
miss the mark and i'd be so sad
if we like built a house wrong yeah
because it's so much time and effort
so much time and effort and money and
money yeah it's just like
everything and everything and yeah we we
just realized like
we don't know if like what's the ideal
size for our workshop you know
do we need a six-car garage do we need a
2 000 square foot warehouse you know or
do we need like
a four-car garage like is that fine like
we literally don't know
just cause we're in such a small cramped
space now it's hard to imagine like what
we need to grow into
yeah and you could just overshoot
everything but then i don't want to
i i like i don't want to waste space i
don't want to like have to spend more on
ac
or it takes longer to cool or like um
like we have to deal with more echo you
know it's like there's a lot of
downsides pluses and minuses you know
yeah and other things that like
as we were looking at houses with maybe
only a three-car garage we're like what
if we need more filming space
oh we can actually like make a bedroom
studio for like
art filming or something like that
there's and then i was like oh wait
that might be good for live streams of
our art
yeah and like oh is that more ideal is
that more ideal to have an
indoor space instead of a garage sale
because a lot of our art stuff needs to
be kept inside anyway
yeah and so yeah there's just so many
so many things as we've been looking at
houses made us realize
that we don't fully know what we want we
know
enough to like get another
house to get a new house like we know
enough to have that starting point but
we don't know enough to put in that
effort of like building a dream house
now there's still a chance that like we
just don't find
anything and if we don't find anything
by a certain point we might consider
like working with a builder you know but
i don't think it would be like to build
that ultimate super customized dream
house it'd probably be like
hey can you like here's how many rooms
we need here's the space we need here's
some stuff we like
like what of your existing
you know designs or models like work
with that and then can we tweak a few
things like it would probably be like a
little bit more of a normal
house not like the crazy dream house
well also since we live in
in houston and we're looking at building
three and a half hours away
driving back and forth to like check on
tile choices and
handle polls and you know all these
things that we would like to be involved
with is just so unfeasible so i think
we're
yeah you know we're really leaning
towards buying
instead of building for this next house
just because i just
we we found compromise you know we found
houses that are good
a huge improvement and that i think that
would be happy with yeah
yeah i think another thing that's that's
really interesting
is what do you think about a fixer-upper
versus a move-in ready home
because i think that's that's something
that i thought i was in one camp
on and i i think that i'm finding i'm in
another camp now
i'm kind of feeling the same so so i
like
i i'm not totally sure why but i part i
feel like part of my like
identity ever since getting my very
first
apartment but then even strengthened
when we got this house
is being able to like like
take a house that needs a little bit of
love and like
have the vision to transform it and i
very much
enjoy seeing that progress and feeling
like
yeah i got to customize this the way
that i wanted to instead of like
paying extra money for somebody else's
choices you know and paying extra money
just because it's already like
finished in a newer nicer style yeah and
also like as
people who have a channel
where we have done renovation type stuff
i i definitely thought that we were
going to be like thinking like looking
for
fixer-upper places that like we could
you know get a great deal on and like
flip it or something like that and and
you know
but but then
as we've gone on on the search we've
been falling from that fixer-upper
side more and more and more towards like
a more move-in-ready home
yeah you want to talk about that process
a little bit because it surprised me
it surprised me a lot and i kind of went
through like
you know i mentioned earlier in this
podcast how
you know the the search for the next
house has been like a journey of self
too like this is part of it like i
identified as someone who would like
buy a house and fix it up but
so i i think i'll preface it by saying
like
there's a there's a big scale between
like
100 perfectly move and ready and a gut
job
you know what i mean like there's a big
scale and i think that like
the change that i've noticed in us
is just kind of like shifting our
comfort
level on that scale because i think at
first we were like
you know we're cool like redoing floors
we're doing a kitchen we're doing
bathrooms adding a workshop
but then we started thinking about how
long
some of these things will take and also
like because
we know this probably won't be a forever
home or anything like we we probably
will
this will probably be a transition home
now that transition could be like
five to ten years like it could still be
a long-term home but we want something
that like
we're not putting so much money into
renovations that like we'll never get
that out
and we started realizing like how
expensive a lot of these big renovations
are
you know because in our house the
biggest things we did were like
replacing the floors
and you know getting the roof replaced
and the roof we were able to like back
that out of the cost of the house and
like
um you know ask for the price a little
bit lower
um and so i wasn't really aware of like
some of the cost of some of these things
because like it's
a lot of it we can do but a lot of it is
far beyond our skill level
and we would have to hire out help and
it can just be
a lot of time and money i think
i think for to do something extensive i
think for me the time
the moment when i realized that i'm
shifting more towards the scale of
move-in ready
and by move-in ready i i think that what
like the place where we're looking at is
like
we can go ahead and repaint this and
replace like replace the backsplash and
maybe repaint you know cabinets or
all sorts of like replace light fixtures
all sorts of things like that
but you know we found a few houses we're
like okay that'd be
the bones are good but like we'll
probably have to tear up
all of the floors redo the entire
kitchen
redo every single bathroom tear down
that wall
stuff like that there's a house that
like we were like i was thinking like
should we put it in an offer and but it
required
all of that work and then we started
thinking through the logistics of
okay how are we going to film that while
living here and because logistically it
makes so much more sense to do some of
that stuff
before we move in so we would be living
here
because like redoing your your kitchen
can take
a month or two if you're doing yourself
maybe two months
yeah you know and even if you're paying
for a lot of help maybe still on the
whole month side or like if you have to
do all the floors in the house
you don't want to you want to do that
before you move in because like where do
you put your stuff
yeah if all the floors literally all the
floors are being redone or
repainting the entire house or like you
know you could do it one room at a time
and you could do it one bathroom
but it's just so much more efficient to
do it like before you move in and all it
once and then we were like so if we want
to be
the most efficient with it then we need
to be living in our current house while
it all
happens and driving back and forth to
like film things and work on things
would be such a nightmare because like
i think it'd be it's it's easier and
less easy
doing these things when it is can be
double dipped with our job
because like you know hey we can use
that time to get content
also but then also we need to be there
and film it and document it and wrap it
up into a story
which means we need to be there but we
live here
and it's not just us going back and
forth it's us and a bunch of camera
equipment and like tools and things
yeah it's so
something that has that would require
enough work
that it would just make logistical sense
to do it before we move
causes so many other logistical problems
if we want to
document it or film it at all
and so i think what we what we realized
is like
we're still like totally cool doing some
renovations but we want a house that we
can move into first
and like we're not
um on the
like uh efficiency side
by doing the renovations when we move in
like we'd suffer a lot
if we moved in and then did the floors
like because you just have to move all
your stuff out again like and you can do
it room by room by room but it's very
disruptive and like
that it'd be hard to get entertaining
content from us like
doing like the the bedroom bedroom
shuffle yeah exactly
you know like from how like moving all
of our stuff from one room to another to
another to another
yeah and so um so stuff
a house that like it's only changes can
be
easily done after we move in would be
ideal so that means probably no gut jobs
probably nothing with like
major imminent big renovations required
more like cosmetic things like
paint colors light fixtures backsplashes
swapping out a counter like little mini
where we can do like little
like like a bathroom makeover that we
just kind of like
can do with our own skill set or maybe
like that combined with hiring out a
couple
small parts you know that we can do in
our own time and it's not like something
has to be done before
and like you know if and we're not
relying on it maybe
as much like you know we can just like
you know if something goes wrong with
the video or there's a big hole that
we're like
okay well this video isn't going to be
done in time let's instead
go out to our workshop and film like
something that can be a little bit more
you know fast to film it exactly but
like we won't have the additional
capacity
time capacity to do that if we're having
to drive back and forth and we're losing
so many
hours and hours every week just to
driving then you don't have that extra
time to like switch gears
to a smaller project if you hit delays
yeah so that was that was our surprising
revelation around move in ready verse
fixer-upper you know we're definitely a
lot more leaning towards the move-in
ready which isn't something that we
thought of at all but i think i think
another thing that's
that's really interesting is just
i kind of thought okay we have a budget
let's just like find the right house and
buy it
and and move there i don't know i think
i was a little bit like naive
because like you did the first house
search and you put in so much time and
effort
to find this this wonderful wonderful
home that we have loved and that has
been great to us but we've outgrown
but like i kind of like i think i just
went into it and i even was like
okay we have this budget let's just buy
the house
but it's just like it's just surprising
that it just doesn't
it it just does doesn't exist out there
on the market and there are a lot of
things that have popped up that are like
close on one end or
on the other like you know it's it's
it's just
yeah i i thought i i just
i i i it's a lot harder than i thought
it would be i don't know yeah yeah well
i do think with
with this house that we're currently
living in i mean i probably looked at
like
30 to 50 houses like i looked at a lot
yeah for this one um but also since we
were here
the barrier to seeing houses was a lot
lower so yeah you just see houses
like i just see houses like every
weekend i just need a handful with our
realtor until we found the one
and but there were also like our needs
were less specific
then you know um because we weren't
running a business out of our house so
there's a lot
more to see that fit our criteria
um this one or this move is a lot harder
because our needs are a lot more
specific now um and so
i did go into it thinking it would be a
lot harder than finding this house
i thought it would be significantly
harder um
just cause you know we have more
specific needs
yeah it's true yeah and and like we
mentioned earlier it it's interesting
that like
a lot of the specific needs that we want
are kind of counter-intuitive and and
and
you know like you know one excludes
another and i think honestly
the biggest thing that kicks us in the
butt is like our desire to be around a
broad variety of food
yeah if we didn't care about being close
to like restaurants oh it would just be
like
far out there and like get a bunch of
land in the country get a bunch of land
and like
yeah and then you can do whatever you
want yeah it's cheaper
and and you get more bang for your buck
you know i think that that's the main
solution but like
we are stubborn about like i'm getting
mouth-watery thinking about all the food
that i
love and like we don't eat a ton and we
don't eat
all the time we probably just you mean
eat out
we eat out a lot well you said we don't
eat all the time i was like we eat every
day
no it's like we we we generally kind of
do like
two bigger meals maybe sometimes oh like
in
a meal we'll go out and we'll split one
serving of a delicious thing we don't
like eating a lot of volume we just like
eating
variety variety i think that's the
biggest strangest thing about us
yeah well and we we cook a decent amount
too but
um you know since starting the business
we probably cook less
than we used to i think part of that is
because like we're
you know we work from home we live at
home so
yeah going out is also our it was our
break yeah before
you know quarantine stuff that was like
a chance for us to get out of the house
is just to like go
grab lunch somewhere and it's hard to
work when you're
out and eat and um you know eating
it's like if one of us is cooking the
other one of us is like oh
i can review this edit or i can go ahead
and send some emails off
and cue them all up and then after we
can review all the drafts and send
them yeah yeah so it's like i know
maybe it sounds kind of silly but like
restaurants are like our
break mini vacations yeah yeah we don't
get many breaks throughout the day so
that's like
you know our little break to just go
have
lunch out somewhere or whatever you know
um yeah so i do think that those those
two things specifically are probably
that you know that are our desire for
more space and
land and not breaking a budget versus
our desire to be close to restaurants so
we're probably going to have to
sacrifice on one of those
two opposing sides i think the
restaurants are the the thing that
throws the wrench into everything
yeah i didn't even think i realized that
until right now
yeah but that's that's the thing because
we can get everything we want if we just
go
farther out yeah there there is a house
that we're like oh that house
is great that's a great that's pretty
much like what we were looking for to a
certain degree
but it was just way out there there's
been a few
honestly like
i don't want to drive an hour just to
like go to the melting pot
drive 30 minutes to the closest chipotle
and like you know i think that to
clarify like
you know in houston houston is like the
densest
food area i have ever been it's like
you like throw a stone and like in any
direction and there's like a ton of
great restaurants in any direction and
if you're like in town in san antonio or
in austin
like they have a ton of good restaurants
too but it's just hard to find
it's hard to to get that closeness and
have more space and not break a budget
yeah like i i'm
we're used to like within 10 minutes
having every single restaurant that we
want
and like every single variety like like
middle
eastern or like you know uh you know
you know all sorts of the the various
asian foods or indian foods or just like
you know great barbecues or like
junk every single junk food of every
type yes in all directions
yeah and we're completely spoiled we
know that living here
you know yeah and it's it's just
yeah yeah you know it's a spectrum
and and just trying to trying to find
that out
speaking of which should we talk about
our spreadsheet
yeah our weighted spreadsheet of
of awesome calculation yes so
because we were realizing like you know
there's all these different things that
we're trying to balance and it's hard to
really weigh like what's more important
like how important
is being close to restaurants how
important is having more garage space or
more land
how important is having it be more on
the move-in ready side versus the
fixer-upper side yeah so we came up with
the spreadsheet
and we put in all the factors that we
were looking at and we weighted them
yeah so everything gets a score from one
to ten
but that one to ten like is weighted
differently like you know
um like uh like a less important thing
would have a weight of one
so the total points it could be is zero
to ten that's
ten is the max amount of points so like
having a pool for example because that's
like a bonus thing maybe that gets like
a weight of one yeah and you know the
places can be rated
but like the house itself we kind of
gave it like a total of like almost 100
points or more
between like you know the aesthetics the
size the
renovations required like workshop
potential
a hundred you know yeah like i don't
know what the points are but like
but like each of those things got like a
higher weight like rent you know having
less renovations or like the renovations
required might have like a rate
of five potential points
a weight of five so that zero to ten is
actually zero to fifty
yeah exactly so if that if that makes
sense so everything is like weighted
yeah and that has helped yeah because
then you can like
grade that house you enter in all of
this information you run it through the
weights and it spits out a number
to compare this house to this house so
it's like if this house is great here
but bad here and this house is
pretty good across the board that might
win against the house that's really
great at this one thing but poor
everywhere else
yeah exactly so it really helped us like
quantify things in our heads a little
bit more
and we also put our current house on
there and rated it because we were like
like okay we're probably gonna have to
sacrifice
and you know go down on the like
restaurant closest for example but like
you know we don't want to go
down from our current house's score in
too many categories
well i also think that like when i was
thinking of this system
and and my dad suggested some sort of a
spreadsheet but like
so thank you dad for that suggestion but
like the thing that threw me off
is um just
like how do we know how to how to rate
things
if there's no control yeah and i think
adding our house as the control like
giving this
a five for our house that contextualizes
everything everything else and um
and that to me just like made everything
click and as we've seen more houses even
if they are ones that we were like we
know this isn't no
we'll still often add them to the
spreadsheet because it helps us
you know again it helps give us like a
baseline like what is a five
mean versus a ten versus a zero you know
having those other houses in there
yeah so what do you think like between
looking online and looking on person
what do you enjoy more um
i honestly i love looking online and in
person
the only thing i dislike is the drive
yeah because it's it's so much work to
not only
make that drive but also um
you know because we have to leave town
to do this
we have to work really hard before a
trip to
like work ahead and then when we get
back from the trip we have to work
really hard to make up for lost time so
we've been
extra stressed um because of all the
extra work required and i think if we
didn't have to drive so far
then we could you know squeeze in a
house trip here in a house trip
there and it would it would just be so
much easier you know we wouldn't lose
like
seven to eight hours of driving of just
drive time in a weekend
um but i i honestly love the process of
looking online
and looking in person like i can love it
yeah yeah yeah
yeah like fine caitlyn like in the
morning she's like
my favorite thing to do i make my coffee
and i look at like my emails for
new houses yeah and i i i enjoy it too
i think you get a little bit more stress
looking i get a little bit more stress
and i get a little bit more like
worn down faster my
my stamina isn't as high yeah i i really
like it so
i've kind of probably taken a little bit
more of the lead you're the captain
i'm looking but then like i'll i'll go
through them i'll show you any
potentials like i've two that popped up
but also i think that i'm the control
too cause like
you know i i think that like when you
find something or something like
you know you might be biased or
something and then i can i feel bad
sometimes like oh
no let's be real about this or what have
you well i think it's like um
you know anything that's obvious obvious
this would never work i just mix
immediately
but then there's sometimes potentials
and sometimes
like so i'll show you like anything that
has the
slight potential of maybe working yeah
um but sometimes my reason for showing
you something
isn't necessarily because like i think
it's an option but it's like
okay here's a great test i want to gauge
your feelings on this
yeah here's a house that like
is you know the aesthetics are great
the size is great everything is great
but it's far from restaurants
what are your feelings on this like
seeing that this exists
or like here's the thing that like fits
all the criteria it's close to
restaurants and it's got land
but it was built in 1950 and
you know there's going to be some issues
what are your like what's your feeling
because it's one thing to like
theorize that but it's different when it
exists if you're looking at it and it's
an actual option
yeah so a lot of times i'll show you
things like that just to help us like
gauge our feelings and talk through
those things you know
i think another interesting thing about
seeing houses in person
so kaitlyn and i have a system we like
go into the house
and caitlin goes around and takes
pictures and i video it and like you
know just so we can look back on it and
that's been really helpful
and then afterwards we like record our
thoughts about the house right after we
leave it
as soon as we get in the car and we're
driving to the next one so that like
it doesn't like spoil or like get better
or worse in our memories
well especially if you're seeing like
eight houses in a day things kind of
blur together
so what was what you know what was what
what was my
initial reaction and then if there's
anything
that like we think
could be more of a contender sometimes
we'll see it a second time like we
always reserve a day
in the trip like to see something a
second time
and um like because oftentimes our first
run through the houses we're looking at
everything in a very positive light
we're like okay this could work for this
this could work for that like we're
giving everything the benefit
of the doubt and if it makes the cut to
the
visiting it a second time and we've only
visited i think three houses a secondary
time on that second trip we go in super
critical we're looking
for like little details that
would show like oh you know those
cabinets are actually like a little bit
more worn
than i thought like that means
repainting them would require a lot more
work
or like initially thought like you know
like we don't like the cabinets but also
like one house had like
you know cabinets that we didn't like
but they were like real
wood which we thought was a fancy thing
but also
there were cracks and holes in there and
nothing like that and like
painting that is going to be much harder
than
than a you know one without all the
knots and everything
yeah or there might be something where
we're like um
like we're really enamored with you know
the lot
or something but then we're we look at
the house more critically and we're like
you know that like the master bathroom
is
a little small it would probably work
for us but resale
is going to be really tough to resell
this or you know whatever the thing is
and we're
we're pulling very specific examples
from specific houses we saw but
that's been our system of like
documenting
each and every house and then like
our follow-up on the ones that we think
might be final contenders yes
i think one thing that's really really
interesting is
our very first trip the house that we
thought was going to be the best
we were actually slightly let down on
and one
house that we just threw in there
because we had a little bit of extra
time and we're like
okay we'll just see this house that was
like such a high contender we almost
like put in an offer on it
and that like threw me through a loop
it's
it's an emotional roller coaster like
like visiting houses
i i was just very surprised it's so
well there's so much more that you don't
get online like the vibe of the
area um
like how the arrangement of rooms
actually feels in real life
um you know a lot of things are like
like build quality and stuff a lot of
those details you can't really tell
until you're there in person and you can
look at things up close like one house
we visited one of the first houses
had actually been a flip house and in
the photos it looked decent
we got there in person and we were like
before we even knew it was a flip house
we were like this was a quick
this was a quick flip like there would
we would definitely find
like issues issues like
behind the quickly flipped facade
there would be issues and that was a
house that we were so excited to see
and that is now like at the bottom of
our spreadsheet
yeah once we put in the spreadsheet it
was like it i think it actually scored
lower than our current house because of
like
all the things that we couldn't tell in
the online photos but we could tell when
we got there
um so yeah we've we've gone through a
lot of like
mindset shifts which i think has just
further confirmed that like
we weren't ready to build a dream house
because our idea of what we wanted has
shifted so much just
you know in seeing the houses we've seen
so far yeah
and i think that like you know another
weird thing that we do when we visit
houses
you know we're looking at it from a more
knowledgeable standpoint now we've gone
into our attic
so many times we know the issues we've
had with this house
we have done plumbing work we've done
electrical work we've done all of that
so when we visit houses we like i'm like
can i go into the attic and the realtor
there is like
can you and i'm like yeah is there a
ladder nearby that i can borrow and i
like
pull like a ladder out of someone's
closet and like
you know you know i'm just doing one
specific example of a house
but like you know i this one didn't have
just like a pole downstairs so i like
got out their ladder i like set it up i
moved there like
it was an access panel out of the way
also it wasn't tall enough so you
you couldn't like get your head there so
you just held up your phone and like
with yeah and like you know i was like
like
okay what type of plumbing do they have
is it is it galvanizer
copper is it pex or like you know like
how how how well are the ac
ducts held up what's the status of the
ac ducts
you know like how is the electrical run
like there's all these things that we
look
you know at while we house hunt that
most people probably don't
yeah and the real leaders are probably
like these are weirdos yeah and i think
that's mostly for attic space because
it's like
where else are you seeing can you see
like the guts of the home but also
the guts of the home tells you a lot
about how it was built
and how it was maintained how how like
how careful was the builder
how thoughtful was the builder and how
well has this house been maintained
because those are like huge indicators
of like
because like you know you you can touch
up a house with like a fresh
thing of paint and it looks like pretty
nice and new but like
under the skin yes what's it like under
the skin
yes but there's other weird things that
we do too like
you know um hey where is the the cable
run into the house and like you know is
there a room that we can turn into a
server room
and you know but also like weird things
like that a weird thing
is um maybe this isn't weird but um uh
oh yeah like when
because we don't really have time to
watch shows
during our normal day so we watch our
shows with a meal
yeah so like when we're eating dinner
we're like let's put on our show
and we can see our living room tv from
our dining table so that's our like
break time you know and
so uh so many houses
like because of where the breakfast nook
and or
dining room are don't even get me
started on like formal dining rooms
yeah like why do you need two areas
anyways now some people if they're
they're social people and they have
dinner parties all the time
why does not have the one big one i
don't know
i understand why you need a bigger space
and not just a small breakfast nook but
like
what where the point of breakfast yeah
yeah so yeah yeah
what i'm getting at is like when we're
in houses we're like
how are we gonna watch our shows with
dinner yeah we does the
does like one of the eating areas face
the living room tv and if not
is there a wall near the eating area
where we can put like a small teeth it's
important
it's a big part it's something that we
do
every day every day or like another
everyday part of our life that we know
that's important to us
another kind of everyday thing is like
we go on a lot of walks
and the hill country is hilly yeah and
like
a lot of areas um you know some have
like bigger more mature oaks but like
some parts of the hill country have like
low cedars where you're not really going
to get shade
and so walking around like neighborhoods
and saying like can we just walk
straight out of our house and go on a
walk
yeah or are we on a big slope yeah and
sometimes when we're looking in cities
you like leave your house and you're on
like a road
yeah you're on like a road you know so
like there isn't
like you know in terms of walkability
there's you can't just say like oh the
city is better or the
the country is better or an in-between
is better it really totally depends on
that specific
neighborhood and like where your house
is on the
like in the neighborhood and how old is
your neighborhood is it a brand new
development
with tiny little saplings or is it like
a mature neighborhood with big trees but
then
that means you have older homes and
potentially bad plumbing and
wiring and stuff so again trade-offs
yeah i mean it's it's interesting yeah
yeah but we definitely go into houses
with like a system yeah
so one thing that i wanted to ask you on
the podcast is
since you have been the lead captain in
both searches
for this home and for the home that
we're looking for next
what are your thoughts on like this
search versus the last search
which one was like i know you said this
one's more difficult but also
like which one was is more fun which one
is like
which one do you have more confidence in
and all sorts of things
yeah yeah like i said this one is more
difficult but
mostly from the traveling uh
issue um and like at the time of our
last
house hunt i was freelancing full-time
and so i could just like adjust my
projects down and i
didn't i didn't i wasn't working like
full-time hours anyway with the
freelance
so it was just a lot easier to like
squeeze it in so this one has
been a lot more um of a struggle from
the time side hey youtube
thank you for joining us um but i do
feel so much more
confident in kind of like what we're
talking about and knowing like the
specifics of what we want because this
house was our first house we didn't
really
know we just knew that we wanted a
generic
house of a certain size yeah we just
wanted a house of a certain size that
was like
you know that's that's kind of what it
was good good value
yeah you wanted a good value yeah yeah
we wanted like a good value
in a certain size in a certain area and
you know
um so this one i do feel more confident
i i don't know if i feel more excited
because getting your first house is very
exciting
like right now i am super excited
so i am also very excited um but it's
hard to like
compare that because i think which one
was it easier to be patient with
neither either probably easier for the
first one because
um i think with this one
we've just we've outgrown this house
more than we had outgrown our
apartment yeah yeah you're right you
know so i think it's um
it's harder to be patient um with
let's think of the uh the apartment with
like the like
my like brown man couch and stuff like
that
yeah oh it's been a journey it's been a
journey
yeah um but
you know i also feel like i'm going into
this house with a more reasonable
expectation of like what
things are within our skill level to fix
up like we went into
our current house thinking that we were
gonna like redo the floors ourselves
and no that will not happen we thought
like we'd redo all these like bathroom
changes
and we also there's a lot of things
where um
if we had known that we were going to be
in this house for as long as we were
and we had the budget at the time to do
more to the house we would have done so
much yeah yeah there's a lot more we
would have done
but it's like when we first bought the
house we didn't really have
like it we just didn't feel justified
putting funds
into it we didn't know how long we'd be
here like
um you know we
we kind of like picked the main thing we
wanted to do which is like the floors
we hired that out we did all the light
fixtures and some painting and stuff
ourselves
um and you know that made a big
difference
um but i i think i'm going into this
next one
um with a more realistic view of like
what we'll actually tackle
and the perspective of like if there's
something we really want to change
and we would regret it like five
plus years into the house thinking like
if we just changed this in the beginning
we would have been enjoying it for so
long
yeah just just do it if you can if you
can yeah yeah and so i think like
going into it with that perspective and
that experience i think
um i do feel more a lot more confident
going into yeah this next house
yeah all right so in conclusion
what has surprised us so far about the
search and you like
broad thoughts and conclusions about
like this
house hunt journey we've been on
yeah um i think the biggest surprise for
me
is how much my thoughts have changed in
such a small period of time oh yeah i
just
can't believe it every trip out there
i feel like my brain has grown
and every time we have like our lead
content we have like our tier one and
our tier two houses and
every single time the favorites end up
being some of the tier twos
and the tier ones end up kind of like
disappointing a little bit
you know and and we learn something
new that kind of shifts how we weigh
things in the chart or shifts our
perspective
yeah every single time and i or even
things like
building versus buying like i think we
really thought that like we'd build
you know because that's how we get
something more custom yeah
nope we want something sooner than that
we don't want to wait another year plus
like for example the the point that we
made earlier about like
we want our office to be big and bright
and and a happy place with enough space
for us
that's something that we only realized
like two weeks ago
yeah because we just kind of assumed
like trip or something we just kind of
assumed it would just be in a spare
bedroom and i'm like no
i i'm not i'm not as okay with that
anymore it's like wait
game rooms and bonus rooms and houses
exist and those can be bigger and those
can have like a coffee bar
yeah those can have room for like you
know we wanted a little couches
so like we can hang out in there like
comfy spot
yeah not that i don't love her being in
my lap i do like
but like you know it'd be cool if she
had multiple spots
in the room where we hang out most it is
surprising how much
you know we've grown and changed as
we've progressed
i think one of the biggest surprises to
me
and i think that you said that it didn't
hit you as much but like
for me it really surprised me once we
started
how impatient i was to like
get to the new place because like it's
tough because it's such a big
important choice for us but at the same
time
any of the houses we've considered are a
huge
immediate upgrade from what we're at
right now where we're at right now
so any of them are a huge improvement
but with the
purchase being as big as it is it does
it is important to like take the time
to like optimize your choice
and get the best you can and it's it's
interesting because
you know we started looking around
january which is not peak season
but it's march now and so we're entering
peak season so the good thing is
a lot more houses should theoretically
be popping up over the next couple
months but the bad thing is they're also
going to be getting
bought up a lot faster and so on one
hand
it's like if you're not if you like find
some houses and they're
pretty good but like you know so many
more are going to be popping up soon
kind of makes you want to like just wait
to see what else pops up but at the same
time
it's like you know on the flip side if
you find something that's pretty good
and you can make it work it could be
gone in like a day there's been
so many houses that like we'll schedule
a trip out and we
send our realtor you know the houses
we're interested in and before we get
out there
houses are bought that's happened like
to like six houses
yeah like five or six houses and so it
really
is something where we we simultaneously
talk about it makes me feel
anxious we feel pressure to move quickly
if something like has the potential to
work
but we also feel like well what if we're
just rushing into it because there's so
many more houses that should
theoretically be popping up
yeah so it's tough i think i think my
last
big surprise about this whole process
has been
how much time
this just sucks from our life you know
we we really tried to open up our
schedule with the
you know reducing our how many main
channel videos we produce
um and then all of that time just got
sucked up and
more by the house search like we've
spent
days just like i think there's there's
been like a whole day where
we weren't we weren't even driving and
looking at houses we just like
talked about houses all day and had like
a day-long meeting about
it yeah in the beginning especially when
we really didn't
have any starting points and we we
didn't even know like
where really to look other than the
generic
statement of like san antonio austin
hill country yeah
and and uh and then the trips out there
but then also
hours every day and you know like
even like applying for a home loan and
everything i forgot how long that took
and
just gathering all the documents and uh
you know it's just
there's just so many logistics into it
yeah we have put like
weeks of time into this yeah over the
past
you know a couple months yeah and you
know i think that
we have been able to maintain a pretty
good pace
you know i i feel like we're still like
delivering a good amount of content
like multiple streams a week you know
like uh
every other week main channel videos etc
occasional podcast occasional podcast
honestly like you know side tangent here
i've really been liking like just doing
podcasts
when we have something that we want to
talk about in podcast form
and doing it on that schedule yeah yeah
not yeah i i know we kind of like
vaguely mentioned it a couple podcasts
ago or maybe it was just in a
post post yeah the podcast page that we
were
gonna kind of break from our schedule
and just post podcast
when we have stuff to talk about and a
big reason for that is the house search
like this just takes
it just takes time yeah um so we have to
like cut things here and there yeah
i think that's been the biggest surprise
uh
for me is just like wow takes a long
time it takes a lot of time
but i think that's that's a good place
to wrap yeah um the house search i think
that we can maybe do like
you know i have some ideas of like kind
of follow-ups
for for various other things um
but uh i think that uh we'll save those
for
for another podcast yeah which means
that it's time for
thing of the week
[Music]
yeah so i think my thing of the week
i just have to say tiny aluminum
extrusions guys i love
aluminum extrusions in general and
there's this set that i'll link down
below
um and it's just like ultra tiny
like a little bit thicker than like a
pen or pencil
aluminum beams and i've i've used them
in the past for a few different things
and honestly i bought them
kind of on like a i'm going to use this
one day type
vibe feeling i got and i knew that
they'd like come in handy for something
um but like i've just been using them
more and more and on the past
project that went live probably at about
the same time
where we um try to make clear wood
you know i'm gonna try not to spoil
anything in case you haven't watched it
but um wow i use them a ton
i made like at least three different
fixtures that
really came in handy during this project
just like in minutes just sitting down
and like pulling everything out and just
building
things and just yeah it's great for
little jigs and fixtures i think you've
also used it used them in the past to
make like
a like temporary laptop stand and stuff
yeah temporary laptop sand and
i i also use that them as our frame
for the um underwater streaming so yeah
yeah it's it's really come in handy yeah
i'm not sure if you've
like i know you've talked about them
before i'm not sure if they've been a
thing of the week before but even if
they have
i feel like they're deserving of a
double thing of the week because they
pulled their weight
they pulled their weight they saved me
so much time and i don't know
how i would have done it otherwise i
guess just like cut dowels and glue them
together
then you gotta like wait and things
aren't right angles and like it's not
rigid and black
yeah blah yeah i don't ever worry about
joint strength no i just want metal
i want to screw them together and then
because
of the modularity when you're done with
that jig you can take it apart and use
it for something else
yeah the first time you do that with
dowels the first dig i made
for the um for the the clear wood
project
was the like hanging rack drop closed
drying
line and then i took that apart and i
used those same parts to build the next
one
yeah so so there's no wasted material
um you just reconfigure it again and
again again yeah so we'll we'll have a
link to those in the description
so cool my thing of the week i thought
i'd do something a little bit different
because we usually are pick either like
a physical thing or like a piece of
content
or something or like a new like a
creator we've been what we've been
liking
um but i thought i'd do something
different and share
my guac recipe as my thing of the week
are you gonna write it in the
description too i'll write it in the
description too but it's also pretty
easy so if you don't want to look at the
description
um you can kind of like conceptualize it
and i thought of it because like like we
make guac
like every week probably like i make a
lot of guac
and i have a very simple recipe
that like in my humble opinion
is like better than restaurant stuff
like i don't know
um and the key is enough lime and salt
because i think that's where like
everybody
else messes up like all the restaurants
um so my guac recipe very simple this is
enough for two people
you get one large avocado you get
one serrano pepper you get half of a
lime
and you do um red onion like
a couple slices of red onion chopped
really finely
um and so that's like the amounts and
then salt to taste
so it's like very simple amounts one
avocado one serrano pepper couple slices
of onion
half of a lime salt to taste and you
just mix it all together
but i think like i feel like no one does
enough lime
yeah like like you you get the lime
crusher yeah you get the lime crusher
and you like juice the crap you get all
the juice
out of that half lime because you need
that like tartness to balance
everything um uh you can
add bright yeah super bright you know
you can add
more serrano peppers if you want i like
serranos over jalapenos because there's
less like pith and i include the seeds
um but sometimes in jalapenos there's
more pith like the white stuff
and um so i like serranos because it's
more of like
a higher proportion of like the outside
of the pepper and it just seems to be
like the right amount
but i've also like i've minimized it
to that amount of things because there's
not really like
that that much waste of like additional
ingredients that you got to figure out
how to that are like hard to use in
other recipes like you you'll have extra
onion but like you use onion in so many
recipes
so it's like i never have to like waste
that onion and usually
um when i'm getting stuff to make guac
i'm getting enough to make like guac
twice that week so i'll use like the
other half of the lime
so like that doesn't get wasted because
i you know
kayla doesn't like wasting i really
don't like wasting food
and i used to put cilantro in my guac
which i think is super tasty like if you
are going to be using cilantro and other
stuff that week
um like add cilantro to taste as well
because i think it's really tasty
but like it just pained me
to always like get cilantro for the guac
but you can only buy like a bunch
like a bat a bundle of cilantro and like
i i can never finish a thing of cilantro
and i guess i could like
freeze it into like herb cubes and stuff
but like that's not how i use cilantro
i use it fresh in recipes and so like
freezing it doesn't really work for the
recipes i have
and so like and honestly that that was a
time consuming
it was my least favorite part pull all
the leaves chop it finely etc etc yeah
is my least favorite
is like the slowest part of the process
the rest is all pretty fast and it was
it was the least necessary for the main
impact
and we tried it because you know some
people like cilantro taste like soap to
them
so like your brother is one of those
people where it just like tastes like
soap so i tried it the first time
making it when they were coming over and
i was like i don't really miss it
that much um so i feel like i have
minimized it
to like exactly what you need without
extras like i don't put tomato in there
because i don't think really adds very
much and again that's just like
another thing you gotta chop and then
you just have like a bunch of extra
tomato because i only make guac for like
one sitting so it's just enough
fresh every time because you know
avocado browns so anyways
the recipe will be in the description
it's
very easy let us know if you make it let
us know if you make it yeah it's it's
like my favorite
don't be afraid of themselves it's
really cute when you get tagged on like
you know
uh in in like twitter or instagram and
stuff of people like making
like you know the magic broccoli or like
the banana muffins
oh the banana muffins i wish i had some
banana muffins
well guys thank you so much for tuning
in to today's
uh podcast really appreciate you guys
being here and kind of like
it's been it's really fun like bringing
you in on this big
part of our journey you know this is
such a big step for us
so i appreciate you guys being here with
us um
if you want to get in on a prank we have
an ongoing prank
where where um i think that has worked a
few times like we've gotten some tags
and a few comments that like
people are finding our podcast on like
a podcast browser and um they're like
evan can you podcast what's that about
and they're just
they listen to it and they're confused
that's the prank that we're we're
putting on people we want your your your
five-star ratings to boost our podcast
enough that it shows up to just random
people who don't
seek it out because they already know
who we are so we just want random people
to stumble upon it and be like
who are these people why does anyone
want to listen to them and you're going
to
be vague in your reviews like like make
obscure promises or something like that
like
make like this podcast changed my life
this is my cat's favorite podcast yeah
like
i i think it's just it's just funny i
don't know it's
it's it's it's a long con it's like a
long prank
you know but like i i think that it's
it's starting to work
so um so if you want to be five star
reviews rolling in
yeah it's it's it's fun it's fun when we
know we've gone like when when someone
rates us a one star review
that's when we know it's working that's
when we know it's really personal that's
like
i was promised this would change my life
and it didn't change my life
but you guys don't give any zero stars
because like then then you're throwing
off the prank
yeah hi guys
hope you're having a great day and look
forward to seeing you in the next
content bye bye wait
i had a plan for this what for like
fading us out
yeah don't worry about it i'll just do
something in post